thank you
[Music]
all right this one's a little dicey
because I do not want to give this
person more of a platform but lots of
people are asking like Hey how do you
guys feel about this uh and to every
person that asks I always respond we
don't want to talk about this guy so
there's a dude who um he like live
streams on Kik and then he was in Japan
you don't even gotta say things [__]
that [__] it Mr somalis
no yeah all right so I said half of it
he goes up to people and like you know
he's just one of those like kind of like
shock dudes that just wants to like uh I
guess like annoy people for [__]
content did we ever do the first one
here nah so it started when he was in
the train and you know how like these
[__] annoying streamers like they
just do shock content right he went up
to some Japanese dude and then he was I
guess like he was paid so like these
streamers get like tipped to do [__] or
say [__] oh I see so he was paid like
whatever five bucks to go up to this guy
and be like Hiroshima Nagasaki and then
like the [__] voice and whatever
right yeah and then the guy's like what
I don't understand and then he was just
like harassing this guy and then this uh
Korean guy was there on a vacation he
could speak English he's from Dallas or
whatever and he came he goes don't do
this man what the [__] are you doing he
was just being obnoxious
but after that
um you know a lot of people take
kindness for weakness in Japan and then
this guy on a motorcycle rolled up and
he goes hey
what about [__] Hiroshima what about
that what about Pearl Harbor and then
like he was like oh no no no no no no uh
I'm just I'm just joking man it's all
good it's all good he goes no it's not
good and then so he came up to him and
he was like what is this he goes what
are you doing and then the next time
some guy came up in the middle of his
stream just grabbed his neck and then
pulled him down and I guess he's getting
deported now that's the last thing I
heard yeah yeah is he is it confirmed
that he's actually getting deported
that's what I that's the rumors but now
he's like people are just coming up into
the street just grabbing him and like
good they're just bullying him good I
was hoping he was gonna get really
[__] up yeah someone should be this
one my dreams didn't come true I think
because he's live streaming and people
don't want to like really [__] him up
you'd have to get in trouble for it yeah
voluntary but he's getting harassed
though at least that's good dude who's
[__] busting up laughing watching
this guy go up to Japanese people on the
subway going Nagasaki yeah to like good
nice people that are not [__] rolling
over like oh my God and who knows is he
even getting paid to do that or that's
his excuse yeah I think it's like the
the tips they're telling him to say like
say that certain thing oh say this and
then they tip it in but it's like if
he's willing to say it then he probably
is down to say it either way right and
they're calling him an American streamer
but I was like yeah cause he's from here
right is he I think he's from uh Africa
and then went to America and then like
he's living in America and then now he's
living in Japan I don't know some [__]
like that but
what do you guys think about what should
happen to somebody that's doing that
there's a legendary Japanese MMA fighter
that grew up in Hawaii that fought in
Japan
and uh everyone was sending it to him
and he's super connected with the Yakuza
and then so he was like okay I know who
he is Let Me Wait wait till I find him
and I was like oh
[Laughter]
but I think um anytime someone confronts
him he just goes like oh no no stop
I just don't understand I saw this one
video of this uh he's like a popular guy
on YouTube and he goes in like people's
ears and he goes like he he says the guy
that goes
not him he's not the belt guy yeah he's
annoying I like him when he's not doing
that oh you're talking about the Mexican
dude it's like yeah he wants like a
little Duvall or something and there was
like some like I think he was like at an
event and he went up to him and was like
grabbing him and then like you know like
moaning in his ear a live event while
they all have like microphones and this
big black security guard comes up and
like [__] slams some of the Quran and
just beats him up I love that but then
the whole time he's like pleading with
the guy like what the [__] are you doing
to me like this is a joke like what the
[__] is wrong with you that's just
everyone's out they just say that it's a
joke it's just like I don't understand
like there's nothing more [__] made to
me than that I saw this one British
prankster goth [__] up it was so
satisfying right so like they were doing
a ATM robbery prank oh good this guy's
pulling out money and he comes up and he
pretends like he's robbing him right
right and this guy next to him that was
getting money out just goes and starts
wailing on his ass and he's like
this is River and he just keeps yeah
good going right and then the guy's
running up with the camera and then he
gets up and he has blood all over his
face nothing gets me more rock solid
I love that Soul bug
s
who walked into somebody's house with
their family in there that was the
craziest the dad just like guides them
out but like like goes into the house
sits on the couch like kids are in there
I feel like you can't do that in the UK
someone's house print you know that same
uh dude that did that prank did the one
that oh yeah is it the homeless one no
he went up to a freaking uh old like
there's this old white lady on a bench
in the park with her little dog and he
steals her dogs
these people just need to like runs off
I hope he gets run over what's what's
the prank though yeah that she thought
her dog just got someone because it's
reality to these people it's not a prank
yeah dude yeah at that point these
aren't good pranks it's all because of
punk
but even Punk was like so much like you
know
is the word creative is that the word
they are created we're just like it's
not as but it's not as like harmful yeah
or serious they're more nuanced at least
and they're usually pranking their
friends friends that's the key thing
celebrities essentially they're friends
yeah I like Eric Andre
you like Eric Andre yeah his pranks are
really good and I feel like they're
they're kind of well his pranks usually
he's the he's the clown yeah he's not
making other people as much the clown
you know there was one where he was
pretending to be he was a construction
worker and he got he he stuck in cement
from his away stuff and he's like please
help me out help me out I don't know
what the [__] happened and then he's
like people are like throwing up a rope
and he's like I just can't and he's like
can you give me an ice cream cone I need
an ice cream cone and then they go get
it and bring it back he's like oh can I
get some sprinkles
like that that's a prank that's funny to
me and everyone is just like really
worried like oh my God are you okay and
he's like yeah they're running getting
sprinkles back no he didn't sprinkles
it's like how old is this problem it's
like when you look at Steve Green
[__] veteran of of the prankster two
pranksters yeah it's like he lamb
lampooned this entire thing ages ago yet
there's always a new generation that
doesn't [__] get it and they do
intentionally want these to be this way
yeah they're not missing the Mark I
think like they're hitting it so like
there's um you know out of the male
population it's a high amount of like
sociopath Psychopaths right like one out
of ten or whatever I think it's just
young men that have no social awareness
oh yeah and they're just like whether
it's like have you heard of influenza or
like not influenza um
influenza is just a fluke
affluenza or like people that are just
they they grew up like in such a bubble
they don't realize like they can they
don't have empathy right so they go oh
dude it's gonna be so funny because you
know it's a joke to you you [__] know
but do they know or they didn't have
parents that would beat their ass
exactly
that's the main thing and when they're
getting like [__] up they're just like
wait a minute why is it happening to me
yeah yeah I remember there were those
guys I think they were like in New York
or something
and they had like accent S I don't know
where they were from but they would just
do pranks in the hood because they knew
like these black dudes would beat the
[__] out of them if they tried anything
and but like I could stop watching the
[__] videos because at the time I was
like oh like who's watching this I'm
watching
you became their devil and I'm mad
watching it but they these guys this one
guy was tying his shoe
and he goes up and he pushes his head
down and has like a fart sound effect
and he farts on his [__] head dude oh
yeah I remember that guy and then the
guy like goes over and beats the [__]
out of him but he's like it's a prank
it's a prank but at that point it's like
I know that's what they're trying to get
but part of me is like
do they need to like break a limb on
them you know I think hopefully that
makes me feel the worst about all of
these examples is if it if it if it
creates a negative effect on race
relations yeah and I think what this guy
is doing is so damaging that he's making
people walk away from these
liking black people less yeah yeah and
that's a [__] up problem like if you
can't do that if you look at comments on
there it's like oh we don't associate at
a exact Community right like all that
stuff but they shouldn't have to say
that [__] like the thing he's doing he's
going to Japan and he's talking about
Hiroshima like whatever the [__] you are
that's really [__] bad and it's not
even it's not what it's funny useless oh
I got paid to say I had to say it
because I got paid like it's my it's a
joke it's almost the worst reason yeah
that's a really bad experience dude you
really want to create more races I got
paid to beat your ass
that's the thing that sucks it's like
because they already don't like
foreigners in Japan right so like you're
making it even worse and it's almost a
justifiable hate yeah right exactly
because they don't know that this guy's
doing it for and even if they didn't
know they don't understand it that way
they're just like oh is this just how
people look at us and if you have to
make get your clout up by doing
something like that is like is that even
worth it yeah some people it might you
know yeah but at the same time it's like
it's really not if you if you if you
pull out a little bit you're like this
is not helping you in any way this is
just putting a worse name on for you
anyway and it just it just hurts
communities that's the hardest part is
it make it causes resentment that wasn't
originally maybe not there like maybe
they didn't have an opinion and now they
do and it's like based off of this guy
like that sucks I think the only way to
make this right is like a bunch of
Somalian dudes beat his ass in public
and say this is how we actually feel
about it
that's like some cartel uh fixing yeah I
think so because they put their own guys
out and with a sign that says sorry
if ensen finds him
oh yeah you probably already did because
there's another video where I think
someone stole one of his buddies cars
and then they found the guy that stole
the car and then he they made a video of
what they did to the guy
oh that's really cool
they didn't get in trouble you're in
trouble I think because it so that the
car that was stolen was in Hawaii and it
was just Hawaii justice so I think
everyone that watched like oh I get it
yeah you don't [__] with people like
that in Hawaii and you're the person oh
yeah yeah I would love for so much they
whooped that guy's ass and then tie them
up and then he just had his like knee on
his back until the cops came and then
the cops just came like oh so he he
wasn't like doing
because he's like the streets love him
so much like people will look out like
help me find this guy to help him find
and he'll just come find you don't
dang like a bounty hunter